is apparently not my body my choice  apparently learning about your body is  so difficult god forbid you have to pee  on a stick every day which costs  16.59 on amazon to buy a pack of 50 pee  on the stick track your ovulation with a  nap if you don't want to take birth  control right or get an iud or don't or  abstain from sex or try condoms in the  pull-out method like there are so many  there are so many methods of not getting  pregnant then they say to the guys well  if he didn't want to deal with it he  shouldn't he he should manage his sperm  well you should close your legs it's the  same argument so i don't get what the  actual issue here is if you never want  to have a baby go get a hysterectomy you  will never have a baby after that